I want to welcome you to this topic, which is analytical psychology and therapy. And I want to start with a lot of disclaimers, really a lot of disclaimers, because I'm not a psychologist. I'm not a psychotherapist. I don't have any credentials. I don't have any trainings. And this is not medical advice. So this is really, and this is a goal of the group and the events.
To understand Jung, his concepts, his ideas, who are really, really interesting. And he worked his whole life as a therapist and he formed a lot of ideas about therapy because he was there in the beginning with Freud and psychoanalysis when the talking cure started. But I want to make this really perfectly clear.
If you or someone else has a feeling that they might be in need of psychological help and evaluation, then please look out for professionals. This is not the right environment for that.
So if this is clear, then we can continue because I could not even tell you whether this is valid therapy, whether this works, because these books have been written almost 100 years ago. Jung lived from 1875 till 1961. So It's possible that it worked back then. I cannot verify. I cannot tell you that it works like this today.
I can't say what other ways are there to, to treat people. And one thing that Jung has not talked about because it did not exist back then is, for example, medication, which is a big part, as far as I heard, about modern therapy in certain cases. So this is pretty similar when I talk about synchronicity or astrology or dreams or history in context of Jung.
This is just to get the concepts and to get his ideas and to get some really good examples. All right. Yeah. As I mentioned, Jung, he was a therapist and he worked really his whole life as a therapist. He trained as one and he worked to the very end of his life as one. And he always has patients and he always treated them.
And as I said, also he wrote a lot of books and there are two specific books that I want to show you from the Collected Works. It's Two Essays on Analytical Psychology. I think that's book 7. Then The Practice of Psychotherapy. Both books are very interesting and I heard the, the first one, Two Essays on Analytical Psychology, they sometimes get used in psychological training.
But the second one, if you read it, you will be very surprised. In the second part, he only talks about alchemy. But this is later life Jung. He really likes to talk about alchemy. And in the preparation for this event, I stumbled over a lot of quotes and they're really, really great quotes. So I will also be quoting a lot because he has his way to bring things on point.
So like the bringing A lot of concepts on point is hard to get from him, but there's some specific things where he just nails it. So I named the event Analytical Psychology because this is the kind of brand of psychology that Jung formed and also practiced.
It's very similar to psychoanalysis because Jung came from there, but had disagreements with Freud about certain topics. In the beginning they agreed, but with time Jung saw it rather rigid and limited and he wanted to broaden the scope.
So he formed his own brand of therapy called analytical psychology, sometimes also called complex theory, uh, therapy. And there's some staples where it's still very similar to psychoanalysis, and I did a whole event about that. Called Jung versus Freud.
And I want just to get some basic cornerstones of analytical psychology to, to give you some orientation. Both brands of analytical psychology and psychoanalysis, they agree on that there's an unconscious and that it is an effect on people. There's a way to resolve psychological problems through talking and investigating and reflecting.
This is why it's also called the talking cure. And this was back then brand new. Back then the idea was rather that the brain is damaged, so it's like a mechanical damage and you can't do anything with the person. You just, they're now damaged goods. You lock them away, you wait till they die.
And to really help people through talking and psychological problems and even some bodily problems was back then Revolutionary, bleeding edge. This is what Freud made famous and also what founded psychology and is one of the reasons why it's used till today. Yeah.
So this is the commonalities. There's some difference. Like psychoanalysis is very famous for the idea that sexuality is main drive in the psyche of people, and a lot of things can be explained through sexuality and how it's blocked or unblocked. And for Jung, this was always limited to limiting. He saw many different drives, not only sexuality.
And he also gave the broader scope to the term libido. As he said, this is more like a creative force. It's something like the currency of the psyche where things happen with libido.
It's like the, Sun shining, it creates things, not only necessary sexuality, but causing effects, phenomena in the psyche, more like neutral energy than something like sexuality. He also sees the unconscious really as a creative ground where things are generated and things are coming from. Like for Freud, it's all very external.
Freud, for example, the superego. Is basically the parents of society with its rules that come outside into the psyche of the person and regulates there the drives. But Jung says this is not completely true.
This is that rules and ideas are not only coming from outside, but also from inside, from the unconscious, so that the unconscious is more like a, not like a wastebasket for, as for Freud, but rather there's more to that generating ground and not something that only things get pushed to that do not conform with society.
And what is of course a very big factor that makes a difference between Freud and Jung is Freud stops at the personal and Jung goes even deeper into the collective unconscious and saying, okay, there's things, there is a psychology that is common to all of us and it's very ancient, it's very deep.
It's, let's say, the experiences that our ancestors had over millions of years that are now ingrained in every human being that is born. So it's in that sense, basically like evolutionary psychology did not exist back then, but this is what Carl Gustav Jung talked about already and hypothesized about.
So, and on a diagnostic front. For Freud always saw a dream as a facade to hide something, a fact that the dreamer does not want to confront.
But Jung really saw it as a more sophisticated way that there is something other in the unconscious of the person that's trying to express something the best way it can and the best thing that the person can experience it. I will go into that later when I talk about the methods that are used in analytical psychology therapy.
So Jung saw use in psychoanalysis, but mostly in the first part of life, like getting people out of the basement of their parents. But once they established, he said, oh, there's his type of therapy working better, his type of psychology working better.
And I wanted to get into now the staples of his idea of therapy, what is the premises that he works on. So for him, the number one goal is, or was the number one goal, when he has a patient, to bring them back into normal life and the normal flow of Things and being.
He noticed that people very often were kind of removed from society when they had psychological problems, that they're kind of shut off from taking part in the normal flow of things. So he would describe it like this.
Normally, the psyche, with this libido doing things already by itself. You have a little bit like a life plan in you. There's already psychological development laid out, similar as when a human being is born, when it's get old enough that it will hit puberty and it will get out of puberty. And for example, later go into menopause.
We have this for the body that the body gets first stronger and bigger and then will wither with time. He sees the same development in the psyche. And so there are certain things that are supposed to happen that need to happen. And the question is really, do they happen or not?
And when the person is not oriented towards that and is shying away from certain tasks in life, it's like a stunt growth. It's the libido. The life is not developing in a way it should be. So suddenly all this energy goes somewhere else. It gets displaced.
So this can mean that instead of that you can live your normal life, let's say in a happy normal state where you can willfully do things, that you, for example, are depressed. Like what we have in our consciousness and we have in our will to power is to apply libido to conscious actions and directions and goals.
But this is only very limited. So as soon as there is something happening in the psyche, in the unconscious, this can like take away this libido and it's being applied somewhere else. So he really sees this as an energy system that's similar to the laws of thermodynamics. Like it does not get lost, it's just somewhere else.
And when it's in the unconscious and when it's doing things there, that very often means there's a complex, like an autonomous psychological force, which is hindering the person in doing things willfully. For example, people misspeak. The Freudian slip is a complex idea.
They're saying, okay, there's something that trips a person up, even in a physical way, that people have accidents. They misspeak, they laugh at the wrong places, they forget things. So it's like a gremlin in the mind. That's acting. And this phenomenon, of course, works also on libido.
And when the libido is not applied in normal life where it should be, for example, finding a partner or just being, let's say, honest and a productive participant in society, it's suddenly somewhere else where it's doing what it's not supposed to do.
And let's say the normal flow of life, as I described, does not mean that everybody's the same and everybody needs to do the same things. Like everybody still has a kind of individual psyche, but there's a way how one's psyche should work. For example, he noticed that when he has artistic people, they just have to create.
If they do not create something, this energy that's normally supposed to be used to write music, write a play, do sculpture. It goes on the unconscious and just wreaks havoc and puts energy into systems that should not be active or now then are too active.
So it's like a cow where the— not the bladder is full, but where the milk comes out. Every farmer knows you need to milk the cow, otherwise it it gets so full, the udder, that the cow might even die. And similar to the creative person, they need to, for their individual psyche, apply the libido in creative work.
Otherwise, the, the udder gets bigger, bigger until it can burst. So what he sees there is really bringing a person back into normal life, back into society. It's not about creating like superhumans. It's not about creating now a psychologically well-rounded person.
It's just similar as when somebody breaks their leg. It's a job of the doctor to get the person back to walking again, that they can live their normal lives. And this is also how he approached it. He would not create super athletes. This is also why for him individuation is not a goal of therapy.
Therapy is rather to get people back into their lives that they can behave normally. So individuation can happen afterwards, no problem. People can also do it on their own. But as I said, the goal is not super persons. What he noticed, which was a general problem of modern times, is that people just lost the connection to their unconscious.
This means It's a kind of hubris of consciousness. Consciousness is that what we can do, what we know, what we are aware of. And we can get blindsided by that pretty easily by thinking, okay, that what I know, that what I can see and experience, and that what happens. It's all what I want and this is all right.
The staple of psychoanalysis with Freud and where he was revolutionary was the idea that you're not master in your own house. There are also other forces there. So it's not only your consciousness, it's not only your will. There are things happening outside of your control. Just as I mentioned, these complexes, they're completely autonomous.
It's not that you want to trip and you bring yourself to trip or you bring yourself to misspeak. It's just happening something in the back of your mind. And he says, when people are too much in their consciousness, that they don't have this access.
They don't even realize that there might be a problem that they're not taking care of because consciousness itself is always limited. It's a little bit like a tool or a muscle. It needs to be trained on the situations and it's good as it's been used before. But we are limited beings in an unlimited universe.
So we are always lacking in our consciousness and there's always room to grow and to develop. And if you don't develop, because for example, you're afraid, you're kind of getting into smaller, smaller circle of the things you can do. And the unconscious is pushing on you to develop.
So this is one of Jung's idea that there's a compensation taking place that the unconscious trying to get you into more complete state by pushing unconscious contents to you. This can of course be again misinterpreted by the person if there's no guidance, for example, about that.
So for him, one goal was in therapy to bring people away. They have a psychology, they have an unconscious, and it's being autonomous, and they should be aware what is them and what is not them because it's easily getting caught in certain ideas or emotions and thinking, oh, these ideas or emotions, they are me, right? He calls it possession.
This can be also an archetype, for example, that just an ancient structure that existed forever is now gripping hold of the individual person, just dragging them through life.
And he, for example, but a lot of people know about Jung is this idea of the shadow, the shadow side of the things that are in the dark and they are uncomfortable or not socially acceptable or underutilized also.
This is a staple of his therapy to make people aware of these things, to explore these things and bring them to light because the shadow for him is in the personal unconscious, which means that's a part of consciousness that could be you, but it's not you for some reason because you're afraid or it's something horrible or something you want to forget.
Also maybe something traumatic that happened. So it's an investigation into that part and through the personal unconscious. And he even has it in a quote, the course of treatment is thus rather like a running conversation with the unconscious. So the goal talking with the patient is to bring these unconscious contents up and bring them into awareness.
As soon as I'm in awareness and bring into a reflective state, this already helps integrating them into consciousness. So one concept that is not very often talked about in, in, in a Jungian concept, it's the one of attitude.
And this is what he's forming then, or trying to form in the therapy, the attitude towards the unconscious, because he says people don't understand really what's happening. So they can be blind to the unconscious things, but, or they can be very aware of the unconscious things.
And this is also a scary thought when you learn that you're not alone in your home, like people living in the wall. The immediate reaction is of course one of fear because there's, you know, you're not alone in your psyche, not alone in your body, you're not alone in your home. What does it mean? What are the consequences?
And the orientation he sees for that he calls attitude. And this forms how it's perceived. So by changing the attitude of people towards themselves and also to their unconscious already changes How unconscious contents are presented to the patient and to the, um, people.
So the goal of there is, of course, you have a whole psychology and your consciousness is only a small part. And if you would even go into the collective unconscious, there's some really old wisdom there. There's stuff that worked for millions of years. And he says people should take part in that.
So it's not only that the unconscious is a hindering factor, something that negatively influences their life and makes their life scary and difficult, but rather there's things that really can enrich the life, like people can find meaning. And this is where people should get a connection to. And he tried to do that through therapy.
But to do, have this, you need to have, have a strong consciousness and the center of consciousness. Is ego.
And this is where you would really try to form the person and build them up to be able to withstand these complexities of life and also their own psyche and their own unconscious to be, now let's say, brave enough to fight the dragon and being in the position to confront this willfully.
And he says for some patients that really have an incredibly active unconscious, that means incredible dreams, hallucinations, visions. He would even need to go so far to tell them, oh, it's all rubbish, ignore it. It's just fantasy, just to discount it.
So just that, that the consciousness get an upper hand because otherwise consciousness can also go under just by the onslaught of all these autonomous forces of all these strange contents coming up. All by themselves and flooding the person in their daily life. What he also wanted to do was to give people a broader scope for life and for the problems of life.
So there's, there's a really nice quote that I want to read to you, which is, the principal aim of psychotherapy is not to transport the patient to an impossible state of happiness, but to help them acquire steadfast and philosophic patience in the face of suffering.
Also, as a therapist, I don't try to release patients from their fears, but rather I lead them to the source of their fear and show them how right they are to be afraid. It's really setting a bigger view on the world and setting it in a bigger context. Like, you cannot escape suffering, but there's a way how to deal with it.
And to teach patients and bring them to a state where they're able to withstand that already creates a strong consciousness, a strong person that then can withstand because those problems, they don't really go away.
They're used in a different form, but it's not like you do it once and then it's gone forever, but rather it's like a muscle that you build up, but you need to keep using it to hold it onto the, onto the level.
And what you also notice is people come with specific problems into therapy, and it can be from the outside looking very benign problems, but very important to the patient. When the scope of life and just existing broadens.
They lose interest in those problems. At a certain point, they just disappear and they're suddenly not so important anymore because there's other things that are more important. So how would he do it? How would he build all these things up? And he really did not like psychoanalysis for a specific reason.
Called it often too systematic, especially people that followed Freud. He called often dogmatic and like a more systematic approach where they like find the complex, find the incest complex and fight through the resistances of the patients to unlock and say, okay, you want to sleep with your parents and this is a problem and we now to fix it now.
So he was against these fixed ideas going into the conversation with the patient. So it's rather systemless. And there I have another quote for you, which is: The patient comes to the analyst usually because he finds himself in an impasse or cul-de-sac. There seems to be no way out, and he assumes that the doctor will know a way.
If the doctor is honest, he recognizes that he also does not know the way. So he is not aiming for certain results. He does not find to get certain things, but it's really sitting down and exploring on both sides. He did not really like systems.
So this is also then why it's difficult to talk a lot of Jung's works because very often there's not a system, there's not a grand theory. Freud, you can explain the superego, ego, id. And be unconscious pretty quickly. For Jung, that's very complicated.
Now I've been doing it for 2 years and there's still things to explore, and I'm trying to explain it the best I can, but still there's a lot to get at. And in this systemless approach, he would treat it as a training ground for the patient.
So in the relationship with a patient, in the therapy sessions, there can be things just tried out before they're used in normal daily life of the person. And there's another quote: Analysis is like a chemical laboratory where people take steps experimentally, but they see all the consequences which would arise if they took the steps in reality.
As in cannon practice, one uses a low charge of gunpowder, 200 grams instead of 2 kilos. It shows how the things work without the risks. So it's therapy in that sense. It's also a training ground to establish new behaviors and new views and new attitudes to get to the good results, to the strong ego, to the improvement.
So on the other side, it's of course, on the one side is a patient. And one reason why patients come, you know, it's of course this loss of libido. This is depression. This is or neurosis, where people have, yeah, no energy for themselves because it's somewhere else.
And he noticed very often there are also bodily problems involved that people get.
I mentioned accidents before, but yeah, he said that people, for example, have problems swallowing or the problems with their digestion or general health problems that he noted would go away when they go through therapy because suddenly it's more a system that's working in harmony to release those knots.
And to check where the patients incorrectly apply their libido, he very often would check where they spent their time and their money to see like, okay, where's the focus of the persons, where they are invested. Very much, but this can also be a way to distract themselves off the things that they need to do.
And generally noted that when you get patients, so people who have so many problems that they are willing to go to therapy and trying to improve themselves and go over the problems, that there's wrong maladaptations at place.
They're just like bad behavior to, to life's normal circumstances that hinder them in living normally. But he, I have another quote here. He says, there is no illness that is not at the same time an unsuccessful attempt at a cure.
Instead of showing up the patient as a secret accomplice of morally inadmissible wishes, One can just as well explain him as an unwitting victim of instinctual problems, which he doesn't understand and which nobody in his environment has helped him solve.
And this goes back a little bit to this idea to introduce the patients to a bigger worldview, to give them a kind of philosophy also with the deal with the suffering of normal life, to help them get into this steadfast position. So it doesn't necessarily be the fault of the patient that they have this maladaptation.
It just can be, in the end, limited beings in an unlimited universe. And there's no one helping. It's pretty hard.
An interesting thing that he noted was he had some patients, especially of a younger nature, for example, children, when they were in very restricted homes and the parents were extremely dominating, that they would escape themselves through neurosis and through psychological problems into individuality.
So basically they could not live out their individuality, so they would become sick. And this was an indiv— way to live out individuality. On another note, he also encountered multiple patients that create psychological problems to prevent themselves from doing things.
He noticed that, for example, for criminal drives, when somebody has a criminal streak, but feels bad about it and wants to kind of prevent it, that they then get psychological problems. This is also a kind of unsuccessful adaptation. There's other ways of dealing with this than getting psychological problematic.
But yeah, in general, he noted that when people go into therapy and are in need of therapy, that they're very one-sided. So he has this idea that when you have a personality, that you have different avenues how information can come into your consciousness. And this is a typology personality model that he has of thinking, feeling, sensation, and also intuition.
And everybody has their favorite pathway of getting information, but this can be restricting if you only choose this, like you have a favorite hand, but you have two, or in this case four. And you should also take care of the other things because not every problem can be solved with a hammer.
And if you only have a hammer in mind, everything looks like a nail, but Life is more than nails.
And this is something that he would bring up because these other functions, these different ways of being, and this also includes thinking introvertedly or extraverted, is something that people need to be aware of and be versed in that, to be trained in that, to use these functions and being then more well-rounded person that is able to, to think and act in these ways.
And of course, the classic people want to ignore certain things about themselves and not to want to deal with them, but they're never gone. It's like thermodynamics. It's still something, some in the background. If you do not take care, it will act against you because the cycle will try to push it to you so that you are become aware of it to deal with it.
But people not necessarily know how to deal with it, so they maladapt, so causing all the problems and then. With time, the need for therapy.
He noticed, especially in modern people, as it's incredibly brain-driven and very rational working and living, it's very abstract living that he says the problem very often becomes the body, that people just ignore their body and need to re-explore and rediscover their body and all the bodily functions that people are not only the brain.
And I would think when he would see today where people spend a lot of time in the internet, which is completely abstract and completely without a body, he would say that it's even more intense. So how can psychological problems manifest?
He noted that people very often have a problem that their psychology is not necessarily contained in themselves. It's spread out, spread over the world. He calls this projection. That means the things that you don't want to see in yourself or you cannot see in them, in you, are still present and they're present in the vision.
Which means if somebody, for example, has a problem with their mother or their father, it's then that they also have problems, for example, with a father complex, with authority. Or in a mother complex that they, uh, have problems with women. There's nothing to do with the individual woman, but rather it's a problem of the patient and their history.
So he calls this phenomenon participation mystique.
It's a concept from Lévy-Bruhl, and he really liked this concept as it means that really the psyche spills out and people interact in an irrational way to external stimuli because it's rather there's something talking to their own psyche, but it's the stuff they don't want to deal with.
So this gets activated and this causes, of course, a lot of problems. And as I mentioned before, the standard problem for him that he sees is that people are ignoring the problem at hand. They have a lot, certain life tasks, something they need to do. Something that is time to do, but they are fearful. They shy away and turn around.
And he sees a lot of reasons why people get then interested in their childhood and start talking about their childhood is because they're suddenly backward looking instead of forward. So the libido that should move forward is moving backwards, activating all these old memories, impressions. Ideas, which is a concept he calls regression.
And this is a staple of psychoanalysis. At least this is how it's known. Freud revised his views later, but this is not so much known because Freud did not like to revise himself. But basically one could describe this as staying kind of infantile. So you need certain stages and you have certain stages in your life.
And one important step is to step out of this family circle, to step outside the psychology of the mother and the father. If you do not do that, you stay a child and people can stay a child, he said, their whole life. Some people go into the grave as child. And this is really ignoring the past that they have in hand.
But there's of course, then get neuroses and psychological problems because life inside of them is telling, hey, do this, do that. And people just say, oh no. I want to stay here. I want to stay a child. I don't want to have responsibility.
Because analytical psychology deals with the collective unconscious, we are dealing also with impersonal problems. So right now, a lot of things I mentioned are personal problems that kind of can be dealt with because they're still related to the person. When we talk about the collective unconscious, it's not related to the individual person at all.
And here he sees the source a lot of psychosis and schizophrenia. This is his view. I want to stress this from 100 years ago. I'm pretty sure we now have better explanations, but his view is really, there are certain concepts that are so deep coming from the unconscious that they overburden the consciousness so much that it basically breaks apart.
Which is the idea behind schizophrenia for him. And they manifest themselves in strange, fascinating fantasies, but also frightening fantasies. And the problem then is that the people already have the feeling that they're going crazy and saying, I have experienced that I can't tell anyone and nobody can understand. I'm going crazy.
I don't know what to do. I will hide away. So people go into isolation, withdraw from everything. This of course is not such a good strategy. And what he would do is trying to get people into bigger scope and telling them these experiences that you're having, they're closer to mythological or religious experiences from the past.
And he had patients that he treated like that and could even help with that. Because he said, Dr. Jung, I'm dreaming of burning wheels and it's also crazy and I see it also when I'm awake and nobody has these thoughts. I'm, I'm completely alone. I'm the first one to have those.
And he would grab into his bookshelf and show the patient an alchemical treatise from hundreds of years ago with this image and saying, you're not the first one. It has been before, and that already helps the person because they're not separated from the rest of humanity anymore. There's still a connection there. They're not alone.
And there he says it's a big problem in modern society as these ideas and the knowledge of the symbols have become, let's say, more easy to get and to research, but that's all dead images basically. So the implicit knowledge is pretty much gone. Which leaves people in a problematic situation when they encounter the collective unconscious.
And this is just a basic drive. People want to be understood also by other people. So the therapist in this context is there to, to listen and to understand and also then help and saying, okay, yep, it's a burning wheel. It's hundreds of years old. So this was a patient. On the other side, there's a therapist.
And his views on the therapist are very interesting, and I think really sounds challenging to set out a path like this.
And the thing I noticed really when he talked about the role of the therapist in therapy towards the patient is something of humility, being humble, because There's another quote: "Where nature doesn't support, the doctor works for nothing." Or, "As a therapist, one can always only hope to see the things correctly, but never be too sure about it." So there's already this systemless, let's say, open approach of saying, okay, I don't necessarily know, let's talk about it and explore together.
Also to say the patient that when they do not know. Of course, it does not mean that everybody can be a therapist. He had a lot of demands how people should be trained as therapists and how they should educate themselves. Like the idea that the therapist themselves should be analyzed comes from Jung.
He proposed that, and that it also went into psychoanalysis as far as I know, because the therapist has to be like this calm island in a storm. Like you have the, the patient with the unconscious, which is very active, acting onto the person. You don't want a situation that it also affects the therapist.
So he says the therapist has to have a strong footing in the world here. Friends, family, job, security, but also knowledge about mythology, religion. Spirituality, all these images, how to do it. Because these things can come up suddenly.
If you dig deep enough, any individual problem becomes like a collective problem just of existing in the world, of being in the world. If you dig deep enough.
And he says, while in the, being in the personal unconscious, the therapist does not have to do much because you cannot really add something to the personality of a person instead of the person itself, but as soon as you have the collective layer, the person is at a loss because it's just too foreign. It's too impersonal.
Then the therapist has to be very active and observe all of this and investigate it. And here, this is another contrast to, to psychoanalysis. While Freud would see himself rather in the background, not even facing the patient and just asking questions all the time and being a kind of ethereal spirit observing, watching, asking questions.
Carl Gustav Jung saw the role in analytical psychology of a therapist really in the deep as a partner of the patient in, not combat, but in discussion with their unconscious. It means instead of being in the background, they're in the foreground. Also to have opinions.
And Jung noticed that about his patients that had psychoanalysis therapy before, that they were very surprised that he would tell them like, oh no, that's bad. And he would voice personal opinions because otherwise the, the, the other brand is just very passive in that regard. So the really the personality of the therapist is needed.
Another great quote: Every psychotherapist not only has his own method, he himself is that method. And also, only man's actions upon man can bring a real transformation. So it becomes a partnership. It is being there.
He noticed that also that patients would try to trick him, but not in a negative way, but rather whether he's willing to follow along. It's just checking, okay, how much can you be trusted? I have a difficult journey ahead of me. I have difficult problems. Can I rely on you?
They would try to trick him, but he would follow along and say like, okay, I'm here with you the whole time. I will support you. I will be the strong island. And another quote, it's great. They're really great quotes. It does not matter what I say. It's important that I say something, that I am there, that I'm on the spot with you. That is the thing that really counts.
So Jung sees it really as, as a partnership and he explains it like this. We talked about the shadow before, of the personal unconscious, but if you go deep enough into the Jungian psychology, you hit the anima or the animus based on the sex and gender of the, of the person.
And in the end, everything is the Self, but he says very often the problem of patients were there's not only the shadow acting up, but also the anima or the animus. And suddenly it's one against two. So. By having a therapist on the patient side, it's two against two, and then it's a fair fight. He put an emphasis on being very honest.
So also saying when he does not know and to be open to that, to the situation. And he would advise the therapist to say like, okay, learn the best, learn everything. But as soon as you're there in therapy, forget everything. So to get out of this systematic approach and really see, okay, what's happening, how things are developing.
And he says it's very important to keep this trust and not trick the patient. There's something also that Freud said that a patient should not be healed for any price. So, and a line that Jung drew was you should not trick the patient even for their own benefit.
So even if it would help them, um, maybe in an intermediate way, that would not be the right way to go. So he even says like, okay, the therapist should stay when they do not know because nothing is worse than being understood all the time. This is also another great quote. Okay. Ba ba ba. Yeah.
This means all in all to have an approach which is adapted and faced toward the, the patient. He said, as I said before, everybody has a favorite function and different favorite way of doing things, their favorite hand. You need to match that. You need to, when you have a thinking person, to talk with them on a thinking level.
Or when they are on a feeling level, talk with them on a feeling level to meet them there. Otherwise, he said, if you talk to a thinking person in a feeling way, they won't listen. They won't understand because it's their inferior function. This is also where a lot of problems for them reside. So the therapist needs to adapt the approach to the, to the person.
And he even says that not every therapist fits to every patient. Carl Gustav Jung, even he would bring people somewhere else. He had a strong relationship with Freud.
It broke apart, but even afterwards where they would not speak personally anymore, he still would recommend to Freud taking over certain patients because he said, this patient could really benefit if you would take lead for the therapy.
He even said to make a complete psychological evaluation and therapy, it would be necessary for the patient to be analyzed by a woman and by a man to speak to the different areas of the psychology of the person based on whether it's the conscious or the unconscious.
He even said, okay, when you have there are in the patient already strong convictions of a certain type. For example, they're really afraid of lizard people. He did not mention lizard people. This is not my example, but this is how I interpreted it. If they blame everything on lizard people, the right way is not to go and say like, lizard people aren't real.
He says there's a reason why this protective barrier and this fence is there. So it needs to be careful checked out why it is there, because It's another maladaptation. It's a reason why this is there. It's preventing something worse. So it needs to be find out what the something worse is before this protective barrier that the patient themselves built is being torn down.
So careful approach, slow approach, very oriented towards the patient. Also to give the patient a lot of agency. This is why he says that the therapist cannot say. He can say what the problem is, but not what's supposed to be done. This agency needs to be left at the patient.
And he would even say that he would play dumb, just that the patient can express themselves freely and explore themselves freely. Another great quote: If I wish to treat another individual psychologically at all, I must for better or worse give up all pretensions to superior knowledge. All authority and desire to influence.
I must prefer dialectical procedure consisting in a comparison of our mutual findings. But this becomes possible only if I give the other person a chance to play his hand to the full, unhampered by my assumptions.
Another quote: Even the most experienced judge of human psychology cannot possibly know the psyche of another individual, so he must depend upon goodwill, This means good contact with a patient and trust him to tell the analysis analyst when anything goes wrong. So I read this, all these things, and I thought, oh, this sounds, sounds very, very tough to do.
So like a very steadfast personality. So we have the therapy, we have the patient, we have the therapist. There's something happening between therapist and patient. And Freud noticed it and Jung noticed it, and of course they have conflicting opinions about it.
And this phenomenon is called transference, which means similar as I mentioned before, this spread out of the psychology that patients see certain things in other persons, for example, this happens very often, Jung said, in therapy, that suddenly the therapist becomes the father, the son, the savior, or the devil.
So the psychology is then projected onto them. And while Freud said this is necessary for the healing process and a sign of, yeah, progress, Jung said it's a big hindrance and it needs to get removed as quickly as possible. Because the psychology of the patient is being laid out and he compared that to a surgeon where suddenly the stomach is open.
The patient is completely dependent on the therapist in these situations, so it needs to be brought to an end very quickly to get out of this not useful situation. So this transference in Jung creates rather more problems because it cannot only happen towards the therapist, but also outside.
So he noticed he had some patients where a woman would come to him with a problem, therapy would start, and she would suddenly fall in love with someone, just, just anyone.
She was not interested in it, in, in that person, but as soon as therapy started, and then he said it's close to impossible to get progress because anytime he wanted to progress into her psychological problems, she would recede in the safe harbor of the transference towards the other person.
So it's a kind of psychological trick that the person is not aware of, but it's happening. It's this phenomena which can hinder the progress of the therapy. So he wants to end this as quickly as possible.
And he says this puts the patient, of course, in an incredibly difficult situation because this is something that is never required from normal people. Like normally functioning people, they can have, they can have problems, but overcoming this, he says, is incredibly difficult and incredibly hard. And this is in general for therapy.
This is something normal people don't have to do. But in this situation, people are already hindered. Have to do an incredibly hard task and overcome themselves, which is very, very difficult. So how would he do it? How would he go into a therapeutic context to heal, help his patients?
A very important thing is teaching psychology. He said psychology is a language of our time. We lost all those symbols, as I said before, and these religious structures, spiritual structures, mythology structures already a long time ago. This is the reason why we now have psychology, because we're re-exploring and re-experiencing all these things.
And he would teach his patients psychology to bring them into an understanding how to conceptualize the things that are happening to them and the phenomena.
And make people aware that they have a psychology, but also aware that other people have a psychology because you can be so closed off in yourself that you do not even have the kind of theory of mind that other people could have their own ideas and their own problems and fears, but rather you're always so completely focused on yourself.
He said it does not necessarily mean that people need to be aware of archetypes. Which is kind of staple of Jungian psychology, what people know.
He said a lot of therapy is possible without talking about that, but like basic psychology, he would say it's useful, but also again has its pitfalls because he said through therapy, people will become incredibly interested in psychology and suddenly become, have this urge to also become therapists and You notice some also only want to become therapists so that they can see that other people are worse off psychologically than themselves.
By this investigation into the psyche of the person, it's really bringing the dark parts out onto the light. It's letting people live out their psychological problems. So the stuff they never want to deal with.
It's like the wound, which is kind of closed, needs to be opened up again so that it can evolve and be, yeah, brought to healing. And he would basically people, just let people talk. And there's an interesting phenomenon is the longer people talk, the more likely it is that they will hit a complex.
So this autonomous thought that in their unconscious. Because it's a kind of mousetrap. It's a kind of— has its own gravitational pull. At a certain point, it just gravitates towards that. This is when people would, for example, start to laugh or to lose interest or just have a Freudian slip, misspeak something, misremembering stuff.
And then you would become very aware and then you would focus onto that and say, okay, tell me more about this. And by this, It brings up the unconscious content. And he said, this can be an extremely painful experience to bring this up. And this can be similar to having a psychotic episode.
So I have an extreme psychological condition in the healing process because it is difficult. It is painful, but it needs to be lived out. It needs to be out on the sun. Otherwise it can't be really integrated because it needs to be reflected upon. When it can be reflected upon, it can be integrated into consciousness.
It can be brought into normal life and just part of the person. And of course, he said, it's not just talking. It's called talking cure, but that's not supposed to mean that people are only— should talk. Another great quote. A psychology that satisfies the intellect alone can never be practical, which means people need to act. They need to do something.
They need to change something. He said, if preaching would help and that would be enough, we would have solved all humanity's problems millennia ago. But preaching is not enough. It's not only the mind that needs to be satisfied, but rather it takes an approach to the whole person, the whole body. Everything that is there.
So he, in his investigation, would really try to get to the end of consciousness of the person. So everything that the person knows, can do, they would push, he would push into that direction that people really did not know what to do. Like they have the hammer, but there are no nails, but they still have the problems. So what to do?
He would try to reach the end of their superior function. And it's only then that people can become aware that they are insufficient and that they don't know what to do.
The therapist also does not know what to do, but this is then where the unconscious becomes active and gives people ideas and, for example, dreams that they get a stroke and an idea of basically how to transcend themselves.
So this would be similar to like, I don't want to call it divine intervention, but rather this Boltzmann idea that out of the dark, when it seems kind of hopeless, there comes something that helps the person right in this moment, right for this thing. Because he says the psyche that we have, it's very old. It's very ancient. It has seen a lot of things, a lot of situations.
So this is what I meant with reconnecting people with their psyche and their unconscious to profit from that, because there is old useful wisdom there, but it only comes out under specific situations, especially when we don't know what to do anymore. So this end stage of consciousness needs to be reached to then get into a bigger, more broader consciousness.
What you also like to do is just externalizing. So when people talk about things, when people write out things, that's a way to bring them outside to be also experienced as an object. So everything that happens in your psyche is always subject and is a little bit muddled.
But as soon as you start expressing it in the outside world, you can reflect upon it because it becomes an object in the outside world. So he would get people also to draw the things that they cannot express with words. That they're supposed to draw it out to really express what they're feeling and experiencing. And this would already help.
This is cooling off the fantasies and the unconscious. It's concretizing the chaos that is happening in the background. It's about gaining clarity. And then of course, to reflect on that. Okay, why did you draw that? Why do you feel like that? What does it tell you best? It's investigating, investigating, and pushing the patient where they do not want to go.
Another quote: A man is never represented by himself alone. A man is only something in relation to other individuals. You only get a complete picture of him when you see him in relation to his setting. As you do not know about a plant or animal unless you know its habitat. And he would use that.
So it's not only about the person, it's also about their environment, the people they interact with. And when we talk about shadow and trying to contact with your shadow, the fastest and easiest way to do is to ask other people because the shadow that one has is very obvious to other people.
So he would also let his patient talk to his, their friends or family to find, uh, for them to find out what their insufficiencies are, because there they're very obvious. He also noted when people are already part in a group, psychologically wise or environment-wise, they should stay within that group.
So you would not be there to convert people to Buddhism or Islam or something else, but rather if somebody has a Catholic upbringing, They should stay in the Catholic Church because there's something in their psychology that's already adapted to that. He was very successful in that, especially with Catholics.
Like, he got a private blessing by the Pope because he brought so many people back to the Catholic Church. Yeah, but it's again adapted to the patient to see, okay, where you're coming from, what do you bring with you, and yeah, how to get you into the best state for that. And yeah, this was now pretty long.
That was really a lot. And I think I flooded you with now a lot of information and concepts, but as I said, Jung worked his whole life as a therapist. So he gathered a lot of things and experience, and I tried to bring it down and A little bit over an hour. Yeah, I want to thank you for your attention and hope you learned something and I hope you had fun.
And this would conclude the presentation part and then now get into, I think, very interesting discussion part. So thank you all.